huge thank you to geology for partnering
with me to sponsor today's video we will
have an ad from them somewhere in the
middle Grand Theft Auto 6 is trending
once again I've been meaning to make
this video for a minute especially since
this happened Rockstar just announced a
$50 remake I'm sorry conversion of the
original Red Dead Redemption for the
PlayStation 4 and switch that has no
mention of a 4K update no mention of
60fps and no mention of multiplayer
support and like a lot of people were
very strongly agreeing with
the sentiment and I found that to be
like such a frustrating comment that I
know D understood that he misspoke but I
have many things to say here and
amazingly one of the things I think I'm
going to say in this video has like
become an unpopular opinion which is
just so nuts to me but we'll get to it
okay in case you haven't seen GTA 6 is
once again trending it's trending on
YouTube it is trending on Twitter as it
does every 6 months or so because some
idiot with a Twitter account leaks
something fals
saying that GTA 6 trailer is going to
drop even though Rockstar has implied
nothing at all and everybody falls for
it every time because they're so excited
despite the fact that most of these
people who are leakas who like people
actually follow on Twitter rarely get
anything right like so rarely but people
just ignore every time they were wrong
like it's such a weird thing every time
this happens we go through this same
weird cycle where people get mad that
Rockstar haven't said anything even
though Rockstar never said they were
going to say anything and then the hype
dies down and people stop being upset
and it just continues in another however
many months like it's such a weird
landscape to exist in essentially
someone at some point may be right about
GTA 6 leaks but until Rockstar says
something you should assume that they
are all lying for attention because it
is such an easy thing to lie about and
you always give people attention here I
am doing it now there have also been
some fake leaks for GTA 6 trailers if
you haven't seen those where people have
like legitimately actually already put
up trailers that are just clearly not
real and somehow people are falling for
them this one here is actually like a
very good example of a fake trailer it's
from Grand Theft VI on YouTube it has
1.2 million views and this is actually
like a pretty well edited trailer
obviously not real but it's still being
shared around the internet anyway if
it's not from their actual account you
just got to click through it is not real
it just genuinely like this is this is a
sick trailer like this person did a
really good job again usually fake all
of it almost always is but he is the
thing that I actually want to talk about
people might get upset with me for this
one call me a shill call me
a simp I don't know if that word applies
call me biased call me whatever name you
want Under the Sun I stand by it there
has been this recent shift of people
just really [__] on Rockstar Games a
lot of this uh happened pretty recently
when the GTA
remastered Trilogy came out and
noticeably had very poor review scores
across the board 54 meta score that is
rough people have essentially been
[__] on Rockstar for that the
quality of Rockstar Games has gone down
all Rockstar Games cares about is shot
cards they're selling out for GTA online
Red Dead online sucks Rockstar is the
worst here's my hot take okay I can't
believe this is a hot take I think that
Rockstar are the this is clearly my
personal opinion and I'm having to
remove several factors but I think they
are the number one like literally the
greatest AAA Studio the highest quality
of all time and the weird flip on the
script recently is so confusing to me um
because I know I've said this across my
channel many times you are blaming the
wrong people for the things you don't
like the GTA remaster Trilogy that came
out and had like terrible rain effects
and was super buggy and there's like a
ton of like really bad decisions was not
made by Rockstar the people you would
actually want to blame for this are take
two the publisher it was a port made by
a separate developer Rockstar actually
had nothing to do with it for the
separate portion of this people talking
about G G online Red Dead online while
that is obviously a big part of Rockstar
games' Workforce who are working on
those games and and obviously GTA online
is like one of the most successful
properties of all time it makes so much
money like unfathomable amounts of money
disgusting amounts of money GTA online
Revenue this article from June says GTA
5 has earned 7.7 billion since its
release in 2013 and is aiming or looking
to cross the 10 billion Mark that is so
much more than any Hollywood movie that
is so much more than vast majority of
games we look at the highest selling
games of all time like just highest
selling games Red Dead Redemption 2 is
at 55 million Grand Theft Auto 5 is at
185 million only beaten by Minecraft and
Tetris GTA 5 was the fastest
entertainment medium across all
platforms to reach $1 billion in revenue
and is actually considered to be one of
the most if not the most I wasn't able
to find super upto-date resources for
this but at least from daa that goes
back to 2018 Grand Theft Auto 5 is the
most profitable entertainment release
ever it's huge now that's not me telling
you that uh GTA online is inherently
good quality I mean I've played a lot of
GTA online but that's not why I love
Rockstar here's here's my conclusion
here of just this criticism that I hear
so often of like all they care about is
Red Dead online all they care about is
GTA online these properties suck blah
they're not doing what we want blah it
is time to talk about geology I've been
trying to get into skincare recently but
it is so overwhelming there are people
who recommend these like 10 step
routines with all these different
products half of which have like
ingredients lists that are basically not
even in English it's really hard to find
information and find somebody you trust
geology takes care of all of that if you
haven't already heard of them geology is
a 26 time award-winning skin hair and
body care company recognized in men's
health hype Beast birdie Esquire asmen
and Oprah daily grooming Awards they
create simple and effective skincare
routines just for you and I I loved the
experience getting my actual geology
skin care it was just a really simple
questionnaire I'm someone who has really
oily skin I always have and I have no
idea what I'm supposed to do about it I
also noted that I always look tired I
often have bags under my eyes but that's
virtually all that I had to do and they
took care of the rest of it for me I got
a face wash which I absolutely love
using it's really lightweight and still
smells really nice froths up really nice
but it doesn't feel like it's drying a
moisturizer with SPF 15 which I feel
like is very very very important and
then my little night set here that I
absolutely love also one of my favorite
things about this that makes it so much
less confusing is it says the step
number on it their products are built
around just a handful of really powerful
proven ingredients rather than really
long ingredients lists they've won over
26 prestigious Awards they have over
7,000 f-star reviews and it's really
easy to see why they just make it really
easy really simple and thus very easy to
stick to so use my code charazard 70 or
scan the QR code that has been on screen
throughout this ad and they will give
you an exclusive 70% off their
award-winning skincare trial set on top
of that you can add 30 30% on the
add-ons products of your choice when you
add it to your trial this is one of the
best offers you will see get it while it
lasts and a huge thanks to geology for
working with me I think it's made such a
huge difference and I'm such a fan of
these products sure they may have issues
with them I don't even know what the
issues are I'm not part of those
communities but I'm not doubting you
have worthwhile criticisms here's the
thing I feel this way about Grand Theft
Auto since three which is the first one
that I played Vice City San Andreas
Grand Theft Auto 4 grand theft AO 5 Red
Dead Redemption Red Dead Redemption 2 I
think are legitimately some of the best
games ever created in the existence of
mankind and will stand up that way like
they are such high quality and they
change the industry they are like a a
juggernut of a release that makes
everybody turn their heads mainstream
media knows what Grand Theft Auto is it
is such a juggernut of a thing and the
only reason that a GTA 6 is essentially
able to exist in the capacity that it in
theory is I mean we know that they're
working on it they did have to deal with
some leaks earlier this year
unfortunately or maybe that was late
last year who even knows anymore we know
they're working on it the shark card
economy the Red Dead online economy
those things are being supported because
that's the only way in the current
landscape of game development where
everybody's getting laid off and
everybody's having budget cuts that you
can justify making the next jugut of a
game GTA 6 I would bet all the money I
have that GTA 6 will be the most
expensive game ever made upon the time
of release the only way that you justify
making the most expensive game in terms
of like a single player experience that
has the level of detail and immersion
and storytelling and performances that
Rockstar absolutely nails and like it's
nuts to me that anyone would refute this
like you don't think Red Dead Redemption
2 is like an absurdly high quality video
game like if you out of your mind is
because of the shotcut economy there is
absolutely no way that Grand Theft Auto
6 Red Dead Redemption 2 or even Grand
Theft Auto 5 are allowed to exist
without those properties having little
side pieces that generate effectively
infinite wealth these games are so
massive and so expensive and so like I
said industry pushing in my opinion that
they are just such an anomaly and for
all the frustration people have about
like waiting for a new GTA 6 and they're
constantly being marketed new GTA online
things when they're like just give us
GTA 6 the they it's like a freak
accident that Rockstar is able to make
as much money as it is for the online
component very monetized online
component of what was originally built
as a very core very personal very
dramatic very violent single player
series there are many franchises that
have attempted to do this exact same
thing which is like you have this one
side of the property and you try to make
a single player version or you try to
make an online version and they usually
fail Grand Theft Auto exists in such a
unique place where they happen to have
the same property that is giving them
all of their money to make the single
player game as like a little slice of an
aside so for every time that I'm being
adverti GTA online and I'm wanting to
see Grand Theft Auto 6 I go I get it if
I have to sit through 10,000 updates for
GTA online in order to get the most
money spent on Grand Theft Auto 6 to
have a game that no other Studio can
even attempt to make like their scope is
just so big I will watch every ad you
would like me to watch because you get
to make something that no other Studio
on the planet gets to make nobody gets
to spend as much money as Rockstar does
on their single player experiences and
that's why it's like kind of drives me
nuts when people compare Rockstar Games
to other games like I did it myself this
week I was looking at the snaky D demo
which is in unreal 5 and you see snake
walking through some mud and you don't
see Footprints and I was like oh no
Footprints Rockstar would have had
Footprints did you see the snow in Red
Dead too like even I did that in my head
though clearly I know there's no way
that the amount of money being spent
even on Snake Eater is anywhere near the
amount of money that Rockstar gets to
spend on any of the games they make for
every comparison video talking about
Rockstar did this in 2018 with Red Dead
Redemption 2 which like okay maybe some
of you do understand the quality like
why do we [__] talk them so much it's
crazy and you put that next to any other
game they're not in the same playing
field obviously Rockstar is full of very
talented very hardworking people who
we've heard of some terrible working
conditions come out of Rockstar it
sounds like there was a lot of crunch I
don't know if that's still happening but
there's reports were there around the
time that Red Dead Redemption 2 came out
that is obviously worth noting I'm not
trying to take any of their hard work
away from them by saying well they have
so much money but they do like again
they are in A League of Their Own I
firmly believe they are making
consistently the greatest video games we
have like really I think if you hate
Rockstar for the reasons that I suspect
people do which again seems to be
criticism of GTA online or criticism of
Red Dead online not functioning in the
ways that they would like them to or all
the advertising I maintain that those
things existing in the way they do is
the only reason they are allowed to
spend as much money on as they do on
something like GTA 6 or bully 2 or Red
Dead 3 or whatever else it is that
they're working on they exist in this
Lane of their own that nobody else even
gets to touch where they have so much
Goddamn money and so much time and every
time that I see somebody yelling on the
internet about wanting Rockstar to just
release a GTA 6 trailer I feel like my
brain is melting because if you want
Rockstar to release a GTA 6 trailer
before they're ready to you're just
going to be pissed off if it gets
delayed and you have to wait too long or
you are effectively like rushing
something that you know is going to be
the most ensive video game ever made
like do you understand what I'm saying
and why this whole GTA 6 like news cycle
ecosystem just drives me nuts oh rockar
do is GTA online that's how they fund
the next thing they're doing that I am
happy to patiently wait for forever
maybe I'm overly passionate about this
okay I get it it's just such a weird
part of the discourse and we are in my
opinion again call me a rockstar shill a
thousand times over I wear that as a
badge of Pride we are lucky as Gamers to
exist in a landscape where we can have
the studio that makes a Grand Theft Auto
single player experience which I'm
assuming they're making God I [__]
hope they're making the minute that they
go like always online I'm going to cry
and leave the games industry but I doubt
it but they are making the thing that
also funds the other thing it never
happens for almost everybody else if
they want to fund the most expensive
game ever made they can't scope they get
Cuts they have a time constraint it has
to be out by a certain date it gets
pushed out early that's exactly what
happened to cyberpunk or it has
microtransactions in it it's monetized
out the O in other ways like the fact
that they are able to exist where they
have this one thing funding the other
thing and the other thing is very rare
and only comes out every few years but
is so [__] good and you can see that
money pipeline is just I feel lucky to
exist in this world okay stop [__]
talking Rock stuff and not giving you a
trailer understand why GTA online and
everybody spending all of their money on
it is actually good like it's one of the
few instances of money clearly going
back into the development and not
necessarily to the take two CEO who I'm
sure it's also going to but you
understand my point it's like literally
you can see that pipeline you see GTA
online you see Red Dead Redemption 2 and
you go oh that's why they have the
Footsteps in the snow that's where their
money's coming from it's just oh I don't
know again maybe I sound insane I might
sound like a fanboy I am I just feel
like every time I see people talk about
this and like get mad at rockar I think
I'm going insane